what exactly is going on here hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we will be revisiting
fellow Canadian content creator Linda
Sun before we get into it let's play a
little game called Abby's daily a hunger
crush and combo today I had like a
lighter breakfast so I'm feeling like a
little some something before I go out
for lunch so I'ma show you what I'm
gonna make we got sourdough toast and
Apple for fiber we've got some almond
butter for some healthy fats and I've
got one of my favorite Bill bar granola
bars you guys know I love these because
they taste like real chocolate because
they're actually made with chocolate
plus they pack a ton of protein and they
come in so many different really
delicious fun flavors so this is one of
my go-to's it's the white chocolate
berry and it's got 15 grams of protein
let's make it into a hunger crushing
combo this is so easy so satiating and
also just so delicious so if you want to
try build bars for yourself check out
the link in the description and use my
promo code abbysharp15 to get 15 off of
your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed here
please hit that subscribe button and
follow me over on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen so Linda is
no stranger to the channel here as I
previously reviewed one of her what Aina
days which you can watch right here and
she's even being a guest on my Fed Up
Series so Linda and I see eye to eye on
a lot of things we both love a good
clickbait title and Linda is legit the
queen of that I like audibly gasp
anytime I see her video titles in my
feed Belinda and I also both have a
history of disordered eating and now aim
to eat intuitively however we can and
since I know how many of you still feel
overwhelmed and confused about intuitive
eating and what it acts actually means I
thought we would use some of Linda's
content as examples of what it looks
like in real life principle number one
reject the diet mentality instead of my
before and after or the flatness of my
stomach I look at energy levels workouts
becoming easier showing up for myself
slowing down for myself
[Music]
rejecting the diet mentality is the very
first principle of intuitive eating for
good reason because we absolutely cannot
heal our relationship with food or start
to eat intuitively if we're doing it
from a place of restriction which is why
this principle calls on us to unlearn a
lot of the diet culture messaging that
has become so normalized and ingrained
in our day-to-day things like before and
after photos accepting stomach rolls or
feeling like that we can't fit into last
season's jeans rejecting the diet
mentality challenges us to reframe and
unlearn these internalized thoughts and
behaviors and not let our size dictate
our Worth or well-being so rather than
strictly focusing on weight loss as a
main outcome you can start to tune into
how your body feels and other measures
of health and progress like energy
levels mood digestion strength endurance
hydration Sleep Quality Stress
Management
Etc principle number two honor your
hunger the clock in my body is way more
accurate at telling me the right time to
eat than the one on my phone screen
fueling for a more energized me meant
tuning into how much is too much and how
much is not enough making sure I never
get too hungry between meals respecting
that hunger varies day to day and never
feeling guilty about fueling my body a
major component of intuitive eating is
to start respecting our internal hunger
cues rather than trying to suppress them
because like a diet book influencer or
even a well-meaning family member tells
you you're not hungry yet
almonds chew them really well so this
might mean ditching a calorie tracking
app that caps your calories for the day
or no longer cleaning your plate to
determine when to stop eating or perhaps
it means giving yourself permission to
eat at irregular times during the day
because that's when your hunger
naturally strikes and by tuning into
your internal cues you can start to tap
into your innate body wisdom and collect
data on how how different foods make you
feel you might learn that you feel
better and more energized by
prioritizing a larger breakfast in the
morning or that more carbs at dinner
helps to curb a late night binge tuning
into your hunger becomes an internal
barometer for fueling your body from a
place of self-care rather than
suppression and restriction it wasn't
fully giving myself unconditional
permission to enjoy it I ate all the
foods all the ones that I used to label
unhealthy or bad but eating these Foods
still came with constant guilt shame and
judgment I can physically be eating the
dessert but if mentally I'm worried the
entire time or even just a little bit
about how the cake is going to affect my
weight or how many bites I'm allowed to
take whether or not I can eat dessert
tomorrow mentally I didn't let myself
have that cake making peace with food is
all about giving yourself unconditional
permission to eat to all foods without
judgment or moral value and as Linda
puts it you can physically give yourself
unconditional permission to eat but if
your emotions are not aligned then you
actually deprive yourself of the
emotional satisfaction from food
and I love this distinction because it
speaks to how the physical satiety and
emotional satisfaction are both
incredibly important and this is why we
need to reject diet mentality first
because without that critical step we're
really just trapped in a state of
restriction guilt and shame
so to find True Food Freedom we have to
kick food off its pedestal to neutralize
the power it has over our lives cake can
just be cake and you don't need to be
good or bad for enjoying it principle
Number Four challenge the food police
the difference between I don't need the
fries and I don't want the fries I don't
need is restrictive I don't want is
still allowing yourself to have them
maybe you're just not feeling them today
see food isn't the problem the thoughts
are the problem challenging the food
police is all about unpacking those
internalized food rules and quieting the
diet chatter telling you that you are
good for choosing a salad or that you
are bad for skipping your workout don't
be so selfish but once you start to tune
into not only your physical cues but
your internal dialogue you can start to
challenge and reframe these thoughts and
patterns and identify the true intention
behind choices are you choosing that
salad because it's diet approved or are
you genuinely craving something light
and refreshing and crunchy with lots of
fresh veg are you going to that workout
class to work off that burger that you
ate last night or are you exercising as
a way to take care of your body because
it makes you feel good it really comes
down to distinguishing between what is
self-care and what a self-control and
that brings me to principle number five
discover the satisfaction Factor going
on a date with my meal sitting down with
my meal giving it my full undivided
attention appreciating its beauty its
smell and taste and texture and flavor
savoring my time with it asking myself
how they make me feel I love this
approach and I think it's a great way to
stay present rather than eating
mindlessly on autopilot and by tuning
into the sensory aspects of food you can
gain more data around the types of
flavors textures combination and
quantities that feel good to you as I
mentioned earlier you can be physically
full but still feel emotionally deprived
if the food you eat is not actually that
satisfying like a lot of bodybuilders
meet their nutritional needs on chicken
breasts and rice but they still feel the
need to binge on their cheat day and
satisfaction isn't just to prevent a
bench restrict cycle you might also have
some physical health benefits as well
with some interesting research
suggesting that we may actually absorb
less nutrients from a meal that we don't
emotionally enjoy so food is obviously
way more than just Fuel and we need to
aim to nourish and honor our body and
our taste buds principle number six
feeling your fullness one word came to
mind restriction my stomach can be full
but my mind can still be hungry
restrictive thoughts make me hungry and
Studies have even proven that just
thinking about restricting can lead to
overeating and binging so the research
in this this area is a bit vague but
clinically we see this all the time
humans don't like to be denied things
that we like what happens if we take it
away
and when we are we often see the
pendulum swing in the other direction
this also speaks to the different types
of hunger that we often experience so
their stomach hunger which is the
physical sensation of hunger signaled by
a grumbling stomach or feeling
physically full after a meal there's
mouth hunger which is a craving for a
specific type of food or flavor like
dessert after a meal and then there's
emotional hunger which is driven by our
emotions and all three types of hunger
are completely valid and deserve to be
honored so I think it's best practice to
start to Foster unawareness around what
type of hunger is in the driver's seat
while honoring that collecting the data
and approaching those food decisions
with compassion and zero judgment
principle number seven cope with your
emotions with kindness so I'm dealing
with my emotions
emotional eating Linda a comforting meal
is exactly what I need on the tough days
I know it's not a fix or a cure but I
find that emotional eating is an
opportunity for me to learn more about
my body and myself and my feelings and
allowing myself to emotionally eat has
helped me gain a better relationship
with food because it makes me ask so I
first want to say that emotional eating
is a perfectly normal coping strategy I
mean we are all emotional human beings
at the end of the day and from birth on
the breast or the bottle we quickly
learn that food is the ultimate comfort
so there's absolutely no shame in
reaching for the Ben and Jerry's on a
rough day all right well honey this will
help but if you're finding that most of
your eating decisions are driven by your
emotions we may want to work on finding
other emotional regulation strategies
for those times of need and as Linda
puts it it's a good opportunity to learn
about ourselves when we approach
emotional eating with curiosity
awareness and self-compassion so again
it really comes down to getting in tune
with your intention and letting go of
any guilt and shame that might come
along with it principle number eight
respect your body hardest part was being
lethargic tired sad really sad being
angry for no reason and just feeling bad
I hated how I was treating my body
fueling my body to feel my best not look
was unhappy because of the way I was
living not the body I was living in but
my lack of self-confidence with the
extra weight didn't help but that wasn't
the root of the problem it was just a
symptom I wasn't going to blame my body
this time this is such a
well-articulated example of how to
respect and care for your body even if
you don't exactly love the way that it
looks and I want to acknowledge that it
is totally normal and valid to want to
change your body we live in an
aesthetically obsessed world that gives
disproportionate privilege to folks in
smaller bodies but even if you're not
super jazzed about a bit of weight gain
your body still deserves to be cared for
and you still deserve to eat so I love
that Linda doesn't immediately revert to
punishing her body through restriction
or over exercising but rather decides to
give her body a little TLC by moving in
a way that feels good nourishing and
fueling her body with foods that she
loves and gives her energy while also
cutting back on alcohol and prioritizing
rest this is also a great reminder of
how the sole purpose of food and
exercise goes far beyond just weight
loss or weight maintenance they both
play a big role in our mood energy
levels digestion cognition blood
pressure Sleep Quality muscle mass the
list goes on so respecting your body
really comes down to treating it with
love and compassion and care not trying
to make it smaller by pushing it Beyond
its limits or depriving it of the
sustenance that it needs and that brings
me to principle number nine joyful
movement the simplest things like
reading family movie night cooking with
my mom spoonfuls of peanut butter coffee
flavor drops lotioning my legs yoga
flows going on super long walks doing
workouts that I want lemon tahini
dressing we love a happiness routine and
I think joyful movement is so essential
for feeling your best and unfortunately
it often feels like Diet culture has
co-opted exercise as strictly a way of
manipulating your body and making it
smaller or punishing yourself for too
many peanut butter M M's I feel like
I had two bowls of Special K three piece
three piece of turkey bacon a handful of
popcorn five peanut butter M M's but
when we
went with Focus to how exercise makes us
feel we gain more knowledge on the types
of exercise that we genuinely enjoy you
might notice that you feel more
energized or relaxed perhaps it helps to
relieve stress or put you in a better
mood or maybe you find that certain
exercises improve your focus or Sleep
Quality all of these are great reasons
to move even if your body doesn't change
plus research suggests that you're far
more likely to maintain a regimen that
you actually enjoy so for those of you
who maybe have had negative experiences
with exercise programs in the past which
have tainted your interest in revisiting
them try reframing exercise as movement
instead and finally principle number 10
honoring Health with gentle nutrition
build a foundation of trust respect
kindness and re-learn how to listen to
my body not a dramatic transformation
the tiny steps every day my focus was
energy fuel Nutri protein I focused on
color adding greens and oranges and
pretty fruits and more Crunch and
textures and flavors and delicious ways
to the meals I already loved making food
and cooking and Meal Time fun again by
trying new recipes I've always wanted to
try balancing my plates with proteins
and fats and carbs and this is exactly
why I think Linda is such a great
example of someone who models intuitive
eating in real time because ultimately
at its core intuitive eating is about
honoring your health through a flexible
approach to nutrition that emphasizes
balance variety and foods that make you
feel your best it isn't a rigid meal
plan it isn't numbers or portion focused
it doesn't have any strict rules nor
does it forbid any foods but rather the
intention is to focus on gentle building
blocks like balance and satisfaction
from a place of body respect compassion
and self-care so while the intuitive
eating journey is certainly not linear
or black and white I really appreciate
Linda sharing her candid and real
intuitive eating journey and how she was
able to get back in touch with herself
whenever she experiences a bump along
the way because even the most seasoned
bopo Queens will run into roadblocks
especially when you're here on social
media where diet culture is very much
alive and well it often feels like we
are fighting against a turbulent current
and my channel alone is evidence of the
sheer volume of that wave
but seeing Linda shine in the YouTube
space and the growing popularity of her
Channel gives me confidence that more
and more viewers are Keen to start their
own food Freedom Journeys and as the
kids say we love to see it so if you
want to take a deeper dive into each
intuitive eating principle I have a
whole intuitive eating series on my
channel which you can watch right here
and on that note that's all that I have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
I should review next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye foreign
[Music]